hello folks welcome to
rational science
it's been a while
i had to postpone a couple times but
here we are
anyways uh because i postponed a couple
times uh
i
collected a lot of questions
and i'm not sure i'll be able to answer
all of them uh so if i don't answer your
question today
all you can do is uh
put it uh in again you know write it in
again okay
anyways let's start with uh extinction
uh are we close to extinction
extinction of the human race
and the reason i mention it here uh
fella says uh talking about ukraine war
right he says
could well be the most dangerous period
in human history
yeah in a way it is because we do have
the power
to destroy the world now
talk about pinky in the brain
yeah we have the power now and it's i'm
not talking about nukes i'm talking
about really destroying the global
economy
if you just destroy the global economy
uh you know
what that means is
suddenly you know money is no more and
if money is no more
that means that you know you can't
produce food distribute food or buy food
and so
millions of people billions of people
die of starvation primarily there could
be some nukes being thrown back and
forth you know that that should help the
process
but the majority of people i think will
die of starvation because suddenly the
global economy will be dead
okay
without any economy you don't produce
food or distribute to the cities where
most people live today anyways uh more
dangerous i guess here is the
right now or the way this is headed
maybe you know one possibility is that
not only is this an attack uh against
germany
and against russia primarily germany you
know the united states conquered germany
without firing a shot like i say
germany and france primarily
europe continental europe
uh
it's against russia obviously they try
to destroy the russian economy
but this is also a war against china
okay it's a war against china because
now the united states has raised the
possibility that if china helps russia
economically during this period that the
united states is trying to tighten the
screws
well then china's going to suffer
and united states really wants to stop
china from
expanding and this gives them a good
opportunity to do so they just
threatened china and they said look if
you help russia
you know they might do what they did to
russia confiscate billions of dollars
that chinese have
you know outside of china
one and any other one they can stop
commerce with europe and the united
states and all its colonies
and so that would limit china quite a
bit
chinese have to think a lot about that
and so you got to think about what's
going on um the united states might kill
two birds with one stone at least i
think it's trying for that and i think
this was planned way back when you know
uh some months ago
the united states
goaded uh
putin to uh attack
ukraine the united states doesn't care
about ukraine i mean they're all
russians anyway so right now they have
russians killing russians over there
uh you know the the people suffering all
that stuff that's good for propaganda
that's all that's good for the important
thing is you know what comes out of this
and what is coming out of that is the
united states has conquered europe
without firing a shot
uh is causing a lot of trouble to russia
which has all these nukes and
one possibility is that if they
overthrow putin
um maybe you get a friendly government
in moscow for a change and suddenly it's
the russia and united states against
china
and i think the chinese are evaluating
that possibility as well
so this is going to get interesting no
matter how how it comes out how it
evolves
i think you
you have to consider all the
possibilities okay
and there's a lot of speculation on the
governments as well what could happen on
the other side
and it all depends on what people on
those sides do like if the russian
military or some powerful people there
overthrow putin you know the united
states cannot
uh predict that but if it happens hey
uh we've accomplished our goal
okay so yeah it's gonna get interesting
the next few days anyways uh talking
around uh that problem someone uh says
it's not against germany meaning the war
is not against germany it's against the
last immense european white country
whoa a little bit of racism there huh
and his sovereign leader the first enemy
of the capitalist empire whoa
russia is hated because
is the last uh immense white people
european country
undefeated by us and unwilling to be
ruled by financial elites
you know and uh i can tell you from a
political point of view you know i've
never
been racist i never cared about race at
all you know i always talked about
humans
doing this and humans doing that but
you know i i'm colorblind as far as
as uh people are concerned you know i'm
not into racism at all but uh no i think
uh russia itself has a capitalist system
and it also is ruled by elites uh by
um
an autocracy you know it's it's just the
way it is uh
you know all countries have the same
system there is no different system on
planet earth okay you have a few of uh
oligopolies you know a few at the top
and and the rest on the bottom you know
it's
no country is different
as far as i'm concerned so i don't think
this is about racism this is about uh
imposing you know one mafia on another
and is any other mafias better than the
other uh is al capone better than bugs
moran or vice versa the south side
versus the north side
uh
you shouldn't take sides you should just
try to be objective and see what happens
that's it and see how it affects you
that's it
okay my recommendation
anyways someone says even if there was a
global power outage some computers will
still re maintain the blockchain using
solar hydro geothermal or backup power
yeah
i don't think so
if you have power outage this is not a
question running a little motor at home
and
running your computer somehow and here
let's continue and we'll answer that
question or that issue paul says the
internet does not depend on satellites
but they are used for some internet
providers like starving well you got to
think of a we talked about the
banking system that's what we're talking
about we're not talking about you know
internet to see what's going on in
hollywood okay we're talking about money
here we're talking about the global
economy and if the global economy
collapses we're all in trouble that's
the issue okay that's the context and so
the uh you look it up it says the
majority of uh our internet works
through submarine cables
now do you because we were talking about
you know killer satellites the fact that
putin at the last moment might decide to
kill the satellites and as well
essentially is saying that you know
satellites don't run the internet
but we're talking about the banking
system and that's up there
okay
uh you need the satellites for the
banking system
and anyways a lot of it runs uh through
cables under the sea
and you think the the russians have a
harder time or an easier time of killing
satellites or cutting the wires
underneath the ocean with a submarine
for example
you know um
are you going to patrol the whole line
with your submarines
so i don't know
if
things get really bad
you know they could kill the internet
and i'm talking about international
banking that's what i'm talking about
okay no no none of the other nonsense
okay so yeah i can say that uh
you know uh
if the internet falls apart
we're dead and i'm saying that if they
cut the cables underneath the ocean or
kill the satellites above
uh they're cutting the banking system
they're killing it and here you see a
little uh article okay there's many of
these on the internet by the way
why mobile banking would be unthinkable
without satellites the role played by
satellites in our modern financial
system
and it says the modern financial system
is dependent on them okay so uh keep in
mind we can't live without the
satellites but uh if they kill the uh
sub uh
you know the the
cables that go underneath the ocean
it's the same thing and i think it's
easier to kill that than to kill a
satellite i would think okay
anyway it says uh
the this article just went in there and
went in
some detail you can read the article
later on but it says several billion
transactions per hour precise timing is
crucial you transfer money recipient
returns it at a later time if he returns
it immediately money arrives before it
is sent
and money can't be at two places at once
this is these are some of the problems
that it would create if uh the
satellites were killed okay
uh right now we depend a lot on the
internet for everything okay
and our very lives on this abstraction
and uh you know the matrix were part of
the matrix
we depend a lot on that and so we can't
let it fall apart if if it does fall
apart we're all dead
okay so that's how fragile
our lives are it depends on maybe a guy
like putin who decides to say hey i've
got nothing more to lose
you know and he goes in there he makes
cuts the cables kills the satellites he
says oh you stole money from us
you kept all this money that we had
abroad well i'm gonna kill your
satellites and see who has the money
what is money after all faith that's all
it is in god we trust
when we become atheists and money
we're all dead
okay uh here's uh not a fellow says
people having four or five children per
family will replace those with lower
fertility
europe may become more islamic and the
u.s
may become more hispanic but it's not
that difficult to uh produce more humans
poor fellow he he's not even
he's not even close he had no clue
whatsoever
no what he doesn't understand is
uh what was in 1963 was the last highest
year that we had for growth rate
since then the growth rate has steadily
this important steadily okay steadily
uh been declining
and there's no way we can turn that back
once a species any species
overturns its population pyramid it can
never recover again and humans are no
exception to that no matter how
intelligent we are no matter how much
technology we have we cannot overturn
the population pyramid ever again
from now it's going to be declining
declining declining until it reaches
zero population growth known as zpg
which is predicted to occur sometime in
mid century this century for sure
and that's if everything goes according
to plan
uh people are not gonna have children
and they're not having children they're
not going to have children and the
reason we know the reason too okay
and here's the reason okay
people are moving from the country to
the city they're moving from rural areas
to urban areas it's known as a
transition the urban transition
red line there that's for the world but
you can see all countries pretty much
are uh
becoming more uh
urbanized
so people are moving from the country to
the city they're abandoning the country
the farms and those are being taken over
by big corporations which uh have these
economies of scale for producing food
and so you know
[Music]
it's it's pushing people out of the
country
and what's what's the issue the issue is
when people move to the cities
it's forbidden to have children
in any country of the world
you can't have children in the cities
it's it's forbidden it's outside the
rule
there's a law against that it's a
natural law okay it's known as density
dependent birth rates okay and so no we
will not have children in the cities
okay maybe one two here and there and
ever less and less and less fewer and
fewer fewer
so no we're not going to have children
and so yeah he says it's easy to produce
children we're not talking about
sleeping and having a baby okay we're
having uh whether we're talking about
whether a woman wants to have a baby not
only a woman a man as well right but
whether they want to have any babies
and in the cities that culture
is gone away aside from the economics of
it you can't maintain a child in the
city let alone ten
and nobody has ten children anymore four
three two one you know pretty soon
that's gonna be zero
um most couple just have recreational
sex that's it no no reproductive sex
that's going away it's uh fading into
oblivion and there's no way governments
can put a gun to your head and say have
children
never going to happen again okay so
forget about having children and what is
children
children is demand
no demand
that has to have an effect on
sales of every company on the planet
more and more companies will be
fighting for the crumbs for what's left
out there people who don't have i don't
know refrigerators or kitchens or
whatever
and uh
yeah what's gonna happen is a lot of
these companies are gonna merge or one's
gonna
declare bankruptcy or whatever there's
gonna be fewer and fewer companies
producing goods for whatever sales there
is out there
and that's going to
[Music]
it's going to be a slow process where
demand does not increase doesn't
increase because population is not
increasing
and what is populations demand
demand is population
okay another foul says
changing the subject a little bit here
earliest evidence of modern humans in
europe discovered in france nbc news
okay seems to suggest a layer of human
habitation uh between layers of
neanderthal habitation did they hang
out or did they fight still no sign that
we ever met
and you go to the article there was this
article came out recently and says the
modern human group was part of an
incursion from the eastern mediterranean
coast
and they all come from the east
mediterranean right
that didn't last long before they again
vanish from europe
um so you go to this article and the
article says that they found
uh humans not neanderthals but humans
in the middle of france uh southern
france actually
and uh
the
the
uh
the group that they found
okay
uh down they suppose they found one
tooth
and they said it's human
and because of that they said there were
humans in france
54 000 years ago i think 54 or 56 but
i'll check that in a second here anyways
they said
uh 54 56 000 years ago there were humans
in france but that dynasty or whatever
that group didn't last at all that did
not
reproduce the population of anyone on
earth today that's the argument okay
well it's so convenient you know it
looks like these people just wanted to
publish their paper that's it
and i'll tell you why here's here's uh
my take on this okay
here you see um
these are the caves that claim to have
the oldest humans supposedly verified
humans okay
the pastera kuays in romania uh that's
probably the best one they had they
found a jaw there and uh it was dated to
around 40 000 years ago anywhere from 37
to 42 000 years ago by that time there
were no neanderthals
in romania okay so
uh yeah i can accept that
the next uh candidate uh is the one in
bulgaria okay a cave in bulgaria they
that one was dated to 43 000 years ago
and that's a little more
doubtful okay again they try to push it
back
why because they want to show that
humans and neanderthals had sex and
that's how the neanderthals disappeared
that's the theory and so anything that
proves the theory that convinces people
that the theory is correct is accepted
for publication and so these people
pushed it back to 43 000 years and
the new uh
paper says no no it's 54 000 years we
found it in
in france
okay when you go to the article it says
uh not to the article but this is
something that i think from wikipedia
referring to that article it says
articles in the journal science uh as
well as in nature said that the tooth
they found one tooth okay a child's
tooth was from badly damn it was too
badly damaged to be able to tell with
certainty if it was from a neanderthal
or a human
okay and i my take on that is without
knowing anything without ever seeing i'm
saying it's neanderthal it's got nothing
to do with humans humans were not in
europe fishing in france 54 000 years
ago the best we can think of is maybe
around 40 000 years ago being in the
east mediterranean region that we can
accept but 54 000 years ago in france i
doubt that very much and here's the map
just so you can see where these caves
are okay there you have the gratimandrin
which is the one that recently published
at 54 000 years ago in france they found
this tooth which they don't know if it's
human but these people claim it's human
so that they can claim that they found
the first human ever to step
foot on in europe you know
there you have the other two
one in romania the one in bulgaria okay
and it suggests still that there was a
migration of humans cro-magnons right
people who humans who entered europe uh
and they probably came from
africa okay uh the out of africa
theory okay
and maybe they went around the
uh black sea there maybe they went
through turkey through istanbul who
knows but somehow they found these uh
remains
and this i can accept a little bit
because
i think by then the neanderthals were no
longer living in that region of the
world in fact i think that the
neanderthals made their last uh stand in
gibraltar over there in southern spain
that's probably where the last
neanderthals lived and they vanished
away by the time humans arrived all they
found were dead by dead bones you know
maybe from long ago
you know they probably arrived a
thousand years
uh after the neanderthals disappeared
so
i don't think they ever met at least
this theory of sex
you know
that the neanderthal disappeared because
they were a much smaller population and
they were kind of uh absorbed
by the
hordes of humans that came into europe
no i don't buy it at all it's uh
absolute nonsense and here's why we'll
see here in a second phil asks me says
uh do you have any opinion on danny van
der mini's theory okay and danny
bendermini uh
has a
not so much a theory the theory is the
same one as the establishment but bender
meaning i what we
look
eye to eye on is the following and is
what did the neanderthals look like okay
and here's the one from 1909 probably
one of the first uh
notions that we had the image we have of
neanderthal
and from there people that said oh they
were brutes they were backward they
looked like monkeys they looked like
gorillas
and bender meaning pretty much says that
he agrees with that that's his version
of neanderthal
and
the official line is the guy on the
right
and by the way that one from bbc 2013
that's an image
that they made of the same
uh
neanderthal that you see in in square
number one the 1909 boulev
uh neanderthal
so we have these artists and they came
up with totally different versions
of what nandotha looked like
now if you were a girl you know i mean i
can't say for men but if you were a girl
and you know they put a gun to your head
and they say look you gotta sleep with
one of these three guys
i think you would choose the guy on the
right
that's what i think
of course
i don't know maybe some women are
massacres they want to be punched around
i don't know
but i would think most women would like
to sleep with a guy on the right if
they had no choice okay yeah
neanderthal has suffered the greatest
evolution in the last hundred years went
from being a monkey to being a hollywood
star
and why because they're trying to push a
theory they're trying to push the inner
breeding theory the admixture theory
they want you to believe it because they
have no other explanation for how the
neanderthals disappeared
and so they they brought in the
geneticist and they say do a genetic
analysis on these guys
well they found no mitochondrial dna
which comes from the mother okay so
humans have no mothers no neanderthal
mothers
and then they checked also the uh
what is it the y chromosome
uh of males and none of us have any y
chromosomes from any neanderthal so we
had no neanderthal fathers
so let's see we have no neanderthal
mothers we had no natural fathers
sounds like we have nothing to do with
the neanderthals
and they found two percent to three
percent they try to stretch that out
some people even claim it's six percent
um
commonality in nuclear dna with the
neanderthals which could really
be explained that we had a common
ancestor eight hundred 000 years ago
and so with that tiny bit they say ah we
know what happened 50 000 years ago we
met up with the neanderthals we had a
great party swap wives
and
we came out of that those groups okay
and ben romini essentially says the same
thing okay he says that somehow you know
the neanderthals
went
to the levant especially
areas around israel and iraq
and over there they met up with us
humans coming from africa
uh we drank beer we swapped wives okay
and he says look this is the theory the
theory is
the neanderthals they killed a lot of
our people
and they raped the women
again you saw that gorilla
he was interested in our women
okay so they raped our women the women
were pregnant
with hybrids
those hybrids grew up
and those hybrids later on killed humans
and neanderthals
and we are the descendants of those
hybrids
that's his theory
and so what do i have to say about that
well here here's in a nutshell what i
have to say okay i'm saying that
neanderthals were never into levant
never
they found some skeletons in a couple
caves in israel and iraq and also syria
that whole region there okay there they
find
some bones here and there
people who studied those bones in great
detail and there's differences of
opinion here but they claim that those
neanderthal those those bones they don't
match the neanderthals of western europe
spain france uh germany belgium you know
the the
bones are significant or noticeably
different the ones that they find in the
levant compared to those in western
europe so you gotta look that up
whenever they say that there were
neanderthals in the levant in
places like iraq and israel
you better look very closely for other
papers because you will find that people
disagree that you know they don't agree
that those were neanderthals okay and
and
my argument again is against that saying
that neanderthals never had any reason
to venture south
neanderthal was an animal made for the
arctic
he would have
can you take a polar bear and put him in
the equator
that's essentially what you're saying
that nando's hills did that they
migrated all the way south to the levant
and i'm saying that never happened
neanderthal lived and died in europe
western europe primarily uh how far east
they extended i have no idea but i'm
saying that uh if anything it's europe
that's it never in the middle east you
will you'll find a neanderthal so vende
vender mini's theory that somehow uh
these
neanderthals
raped our women
and uh and then the offspring of those
killed both neanderthals and humans and
and they were the survivors and we come
from that scot stock that's only based
on
again he wants to be at peace with the
establishment
and i'm saying none of that has anything
to do with how the neanderthals
disappeared the neanderthals disappeared
when their population pyramid overturned
and they lost their genetic diversity
two whammies that they got and uh and
that's the same for any species that
dies in a background extinction so the
mechanism for background exchange is the
same for any species as far as i'm
concerned okay so that's
that's where i stand
okay moving on to a couple other issues
we had the loonies and the moonies and
we have a couple people who are still
trying to struggle with the spin issue
okay i'm just gonna mention them one
file says have you ever watched the moon
for an entire night take photos every
hour the moon sure rotates it does not
spin
rotate but does not spin you look up the
word rotate says to cause to turn around
an axis or center point to revolve and
what is uh spin you look it up it says
revolve or to rotate
and then another fellow over there shows
why we can't use these synonyms because
they all get confused and they they they
talk past each other fella says the moon
does not spin on its axis
but it is sure but it sure does rotate
meaning orbit around the earth
you see where the problem is these
people go back and forth because they
use the wrong words they're using the
word rotate without defining it
and one guy means orbit the other guy
means spin that's the problem okay and
so
you know this is what i said the other
days and i'll say it one more time for
last time i hope uh and that spin to
turn around an axis and to orbit to move
in a curved path around another object
okay so does the moon orbit the earth
yes
does the moon spin no okay why doesn't
it spin because it does not turn around
its axes
and then the idiot comes in there and
says oh but it does because see it takes
27 days to turn around its axis very
slow top
no it doesn't turn around its axis
because the axis is rotating with the
moon
okay you can can't use a one-dimensional
axis which is what the mathematicians
use
you cannot imagine a one-dimensional
axis
spinning let alone
imagine a one dimension an axis one
dimensional axis to begin with
so no so the issue never popped up in
the minds of the mathematicians whether
the axis the one dimensional axis is
spinning together with a moon
so the fact that the moon goes
in other words orbits around the earth
does not mean it spins on its axis like
a top spins on its axis and they say
well it takes 27 days to spin on its
axis absolutely not because the axis is
spinning together with the moon if we
were to
you know select a mountain or a valley
on the surface of the moon and we could
put a stick a three-dimensional
imaginable steak not an unimaginable
one-dimensional steak but a
three-dimensional stick right through
the moon and we hold it still
the moon would not be that mountain
would not be changing its location with
respect to the axis
a three dimensional axis
to the atoms that comprise the three
dimensional axis that's physics now
mathematics they don't care about that
so they put a one-dimensional axis and
they say yeah the moon spins
because it rotates what do you mean by
rotate that spins on this axis
so they're chasing their tails around
because they don't define these terms
that's what it's all about
okay another fellow says
says ah went to the other side give me a
second here
oh says
here it is so the moon does not spin
because its axis is tidally locked
uh to the object which the moon's axis
is orbiting have i understood that
correctly
poor valor
what does tidally locks
have anything to do with uh spinning
does the um
does the top spin because it's tightly
locked with the walls of your house is
that how you determine whether the top
is spinning
my god no we define the word spin and
then if it matches the definition we
call it that we say that the top is
spinning and if
the moon matches the definition of the
word spin we say the moon is spinning
the problem is it doesn't
why because spin requires that the axis
stands still and the
mountain on the outside on the surface
change its location with respect to
every atom of that axis three
dimensional axis not one dimensional
mathematical axis no such thing in
physics
okay and here we have another phone and
he's a flat earther and he says funny
how some people still believe in nukes
and satellites
do you think you ever saw a real
satellite image
my poor god
uh yeah you have people who are still
living in the stone age and my only
question is
what are these people doing in science
they should be in church praying or you
know clean latrines or something they
don't have the brains to do science
why why do these people come into to
science sites what are they looking for
and and this is what
google's my mind you know i mean
uh flat earthers you know what are they
doing in physics
okay moving on now let's move to uh the
subject matter today which is space time
what in the world is space time
and
i'm going to start with ether
because the ether has something to do
with space-time okay
um
general relativity special relativity it
it kind of led to
relativity and also quantum mechanics
for that matter
and it's because in the 19th century
pretty much everyone believed in the
ether that there was this medium out
there
what i call a bunch of particles okay
a lot of people get offended they said
oh it's not not a bunch of particles
and yeah it's a bunch of particles
that's what the ether is and um but the
scholars of the 19th century believed
was that light was a vibration of the
ether
meaning what of the particles of the
ether which is the correct way of saying
it when people say it's the vibration of
the ether that's where they make the big
booboo grammatical and semantic error
and they don't realize that they say
that's the vibration of the ether you
can't say that
that's like saying that
um it's the vibration of the forest
or you can say the
vibration of a tree you can say that the
tree is shaking but you can't say the
forest is shaking
okay and that's the difference between a
particle or a few particles within the
ether that make up the ether and to say
that the ether is vibrating and that uh
electromagnetic wave or transverse wave
is the vibration of the ether
no no the the forest does not vibrate
there is no waving of the forest because
if the forest waves then it weighs with
respect to
to something outside the forest
forest is not a physical object
now it could under one context you know
you go to a kindergarten and the baby
you know the two three four year old
toddler he goes in there and he draws
something
and what does he draw well he draws you
know a green region on his paper
and someone asked him what is that he
says that's the forest
okay
but then you can't go in there and say
well
the tree is vibra is you know the air is
blowing one of the leaves of a tree
you know you can say
you can't talk about the tree because
the forest is all the trees and now
we're going to talk about the forest you
either talk about tree or you talk about
forest you can't say that because a
forest is made out of trees and the wind
blew the tree and shipped the tree that
the
forest is shaking
and that's the air these people commit
with the ether they think that because
light is the vibration of the ether when
they really mean vibration of the
particles that comprise the ether
if you're going to talk about that talk
about the particles don't talk about the
ether okay ether is the whole shebang
you can't say the whole shebang vibrates
okay i hope some some gun got the
message okay anyways we start with uh
issue of a person raised and he says
bill can't explain where the ropes comes
from the origin of the ropes are from
the medium itself that they called ether
an aetherius guy here
which is not a bunch of particles as he
states
if conception it's conceptually an
incomprehen
incompressible fluid
okay let's look at what a fluid is fluid
is a liquid gas or other material blah
blah blah blah blah blah
so what's a liquid gasser material well
you look them up it's a bunch of
particles
so all he said is that yeah the ether is
a bunch of particles but bill said it's
a bunch of particles i don't agree with
them i think it's a bunch of particles
you say it's the fluid
what is a fluid
there is no physical object called fluid
okay like there's no physical object
called solids or gases
okay these are categories
uh what they call state of matter states
of matter
so you can't say that ether is a fluid
because you haven't said anything
and again you either talk about the
ocean or you talk about the drops of
water that comprise the ocean or the
molecules that comprise the ocean or the
atoms that comprise the ocean
okay you can't say the ocean
waves because
you know a little bit of water wave you
either talk about the little bit of
water you talk about the ocean you can't
talk about both
you can't ex you can't generalize and
say the ocean waved
if the ocean waved
then the ocean waved with respect to
something else okay let's get the
semantics right people
never learn to talk
and so
these people are confusing you know the
what's the particles that comprise the
ether with the ether okay
and regarding what he said that ropes uh
you know he says i can't explain where
the orbs come from
i've already mentioned that quite a bit
so let's go through it one more time
single thread
is all there is in the entire universe
under the rope model this thread turns
into ropes atoms ropes atoms ropes atoms
we're done it's been there forever
why because something cannot convert
into nothing and nothing cannot convert
into something
we're done
so there is no origin to matter as in
religion as in mathematical physics
where they say that
matter came into being
and people say well that's not really
what big bang says you know
big bang just stops
just short of that just shy of that
first frame of the film
well they're wrong also there because it
turns out that in quantum mechanics they
say particles coming from the void
they're created from nothing
and then they go back to being nothing
so in mathematical physics they do have
creation of matter they say nothing
turns into two particles and two
particles turns into nothing
called a virtual particle that cannot be
experimentally verified it's just
mathematically
put ad hoc
am i getting through to anyone there
okay so that's the issue the issue is
yes mathematical physics like
traditional religions believes in the
creation of matter
they think that space nothing
can turn into something spontaneously
length width and height suddenly pop in
you know the rabbit pops in from nothing
that's what they believe in
and what we're saying is no matter is
eternal why because matter cannot turn
into space nothing
and nothing space vacuum cannot turn
into something three dimension you know
length width and height
period we're done
and because space is not a thing
it does not have a surface it does not
have form
therefore
no object not even god
can leave space because there is no
boundary no surface to cross
because space is nothing meaning it has
no shape
i hope someone got that
okay but where do we get this ether
thingy okay well let's go back in time
because people
still insist no no
the ether is is something that's not a
bunch of particles so let's prove to
these people they like proof they like
evidence okay let's prove to them that
the ether is bunch of particles that's
the definition of ether again ether is
not a physical object it's a concept
abstract concept means bunch of
particles a bunch of particles does not
an object mate okay a bunch of particles
is not an object object is that which
you can point to you point to an
elephant not to a bunch of particles you
point to the table not to a bunch of
particles that comprise the table table
is the whole thing not each individual
particle the billions of particles that
comprise the table
okay we got that
my god okay so here we have it now we
have robert boyle he's one of the first
guys who did it
who came up with this notion of ether
actually it was several people tori
chile before him already talked about
you know particles of the vacuum or
whether the vacuum was comprised of
particles another one was pon gerica who
did the first vacuum pump
anyways uh ether consists of subtle
particles that's what robert boyle said
in uh around 160s
in the 1660s he said this or maybe even
a little earlier maybe late 1650s
anyways isaac newton i do not know what
this ether is but if it consists of
particles right particles then they must
be exceedingly smaller than those of air
the exceeding smallness of its particles
talking about the ether of its particles
right i hope people are listening i said
the word particle okay
many contribute may contribute to the
greatness of the force by which those
particles right may recede from one
another
thomas young couple centuries later says
the ether consists of mutually repelling
subtle particles which are attracted to
particles of matter
what is the ether it's a bunch of
particles anyone who says anything
different is an ignoramus
it hasn't done any research on the word
ether they start using the ether they
say oh the that's this the ether descent
and they don't even know what the ether
is so when i tell them it's a bunch of
particles they say oh what do you mean
what are you talking about bill what do
you mean it's a bunch of particles yeah
that's what it's always been since the
days of the greeks it's been a bunch of
particles there has never
in the history of human
existence
any other proposal
than particles it's always been
particles
you talk about waves it's particles
you talk about magnetism it's particles
it's done with particles media it's uh
mediated it's simulated with particles
you talk about field particles energy
particles mass particles it's always
been particles
where have you been
there's never been any other proposal
until i came along and said all
atoms in the universe are physically
interconnected there's a single thread
in the universe that's a totally
different setup until that came along
it's always been particles both
the official mathematical establishment
and the dissonance they all believe in
particles there's not a single person on
planet earth that has ever come up with
anything other than particles so when
you say oh it's a fluid oh it's a field
what are you saying what is the field
what is the fluid particles that's what
you're saying
you may not like it because you never
thought about what you're talking about
but that's what it's been and that's
what all these people used to say
it's particles particles particles
particles you won't get away from
particles and i'll beat it into your
brain that it's particles it's always
been particles okay here's the next
group of people more evidence more proof
for those who believe the ether
something other than bunch o particles
right
james maxwell ether medium for a
propagation of light waves light must be
a wave process in a medium rather than a
substance well what is the difference
between a medium and a substance dear
james
okay
and then he goes and shows how the
phenomena of polarization fits in with
wave theory okay great properties of the
ether include all these things well what
is he talking about if it's elastic if
it's got density what are we talking
about well he's talking about particles
okay
and then he says he distinguishes ether
from gross
matter well how is it different i mean
we're talking about particles here and
particles there
direct see another notion that came
later again it's an ether and what was
it a theoretical model of the vacuum as
an infinite sea of what particles
math physics today virtual particles
that's what they're talking about
excitations of the underlying fields
what are fields particles
but are temporary in the sense that they
appear in calculations of interactions
the accuracy and use of virtual
particles in calculation
is firmly established but they cannot be
detected in experiments i love that they
can't detect it in experiments but it's
been firmly established why because
they're particles because they simulate
everything with particles
so anyone who says that
uh ethers not a bunch of particles what
you this is the homework you got to do
you got to tell me what it is in it
instead and don't tell me it's a field
don't tell me it's a fluid you got to
come up with a physical object if you're
going to use ether as a physical object
and it can't be the whole thing if
you're going to talk about the ether
we're going to talk about the whole
shebang you can't say well some
vibrations of the ether here inside is
what light is you can't say that
okay because then you're talking about
the particles that comprise the ether
you got that okay let's hope that sinks
in okay and here we have robert laughlin
and again i've mentioned this a couple
times before but here one more time the
modern concept of the vacuum of space
confirmed by er every day by experiment
is a relativistic ether but we do not
call it this because it is taboo
this man nobel prize hopefully he
outranks you so you better listen to him
he's saying that
uh the vacuum that is used today but by
both uh
quantum mechanics and uh
general relativity is an ether
but they don't call it that because the
word
is a no-no ever since you know they got
rid of the
you know the uh ether word they don't
want to bring it back but it's an ether
and why is this important today because
space-time as you will see is an ether
theory okay we'll get to that in a
second
okay here's the uh dynamic ether you
ever wanted to know what ether looks
like
okay well i can't show you what it looks
like in one shot because it's always
moving around remember that ether
vibrates meaning the particles of ether
are vibrating here they are that's the
ether
you always wanted to know what the ether
looks like there it is i made it visible
for you all that invisible stuff that's
in the background you know
and
you might say well you know
light is the waving of the ether okay so
here's a waving of the ether okay but is
are we talking about the waving of the
whole ether the whole shebang are we
talking about uh
what are we saying here we're saying
that
maybe it's just a few particles that are
vibrating is that what the ether is
see you either talk about the whole
shebang and say the whole ether waves
or you don't use the word ether you have
to talk about the particles that
comprise the ether and otherwise you got
to tell me what the ether is
and so here's a static image of the
ether okay for those because some people
believe that the ether is static and
light moves through it okay and so here
it is that's the static ether you might
say well that's the ether okay so now
you have it so you got to tell me what
the ether is and you can't say well
ether is a bunch of particles uh because
that's a definition that's not a thing
okay you can't say then the ether
vibrates
okay so either either you point to the
ether and tell me what the shape of it
looks like
or you tell me what each individual
particle looks like and for that matter
you would have to tell me what
encapsulates each particle and here let
me show you an example here this is a
particle okay
it's white
and we don't care about the particle we
want to know what the black stuff is
which is the one that nobody wants to
identify everybody wants to talk about
the particle and say that's a particle
of ether
or that's you know a field particle or a
particle of energy or a particle of mass
or whatever we don't care about the
particle we want to know what the black
stuff is that contours give shape to the
particle and the reason for that is if
you have many particles like in this
case here okay
you know for you to identify each one of
those particles as a separate discrete
entity
it's got to be separated from all the
rest otherwise this would be a single
block
and so we again we need to find out what
the black stuff is that's what we're
interested in that's what nobody can
identify
and you might say well that's space
okay you got to tell me now what space
is
and the question is whether space is an
object because you say space but so far
you haven't said anything all you said
is that's x
and so i want to know what that x is is
is what is that black stuff
and you say well that's space is space a
physical object is it finite is it
infinite
and some people say space is infinite
others say space is finite
you know we have all these versions out
there still after 10 000 years we
haven't resolved that issue you have
people on one side people on the other
side they just use it any way they want
you know uh and you say okay so what is
this space is it an object well if
you're going to talk about being finite
or infinite you're applying an adjective
in physics remember we're talking about
physics not ordinary speech here okay
you're applying an adjective you can
only use adjective to describe
objects
and so if you say infinite or finite
you're applying an adjective to a noun
you're treating space as a physical
object either way so it doesn't matter
and so
assuming you say that space is a
physical object you got to show me the
space the the shape of space and okay
you say that's what the black stuff
that's what space looks like now you got
to tell me what the white stuff is
what's what's contouring space
and hopefully you don't say that
that white stuff is an object too
because then i'm going to ask you what
contour is that
and we can go on and on and infinitum
and that's it shows you why
at some point the bug has to stop you
can't continue pushing the buck
some point you got to tell me what
contours it all
and you can't keep pushing it
out into no man's land say well i don't
know what's out there and then you don't
have a case
in science it's very simple very
straightforward space is that which
doesn't have shape
meaning there's nothing outside of space
because otherwise it would have shape
okay and so space is that which doesn't
have shape serves as backdrop if you
could call it that to matter which is
what has shape okay so the objects uh in
uh
like atoms and so on they're all
contoured by this space thingy which is
not a thingy it's just that which
doesn't have shape
and because it's that which doesn't have
shape
it's not infinite or finite because it's
not an object nothing is a concept not a
thing
okay that's why it's called nah think
it's the opposite of thing okay so thing
is that which has shape and nothing is
that which doesn't have shape they are
antonyms nothing is what gives
contour or shape to what does have shape
okay provides a contrast
and so
something cannot turn into nothing
nothing cannot turn into something
therefore the some things have always
been there
the thread has always been there the
thread had no origin there's no god that
made it
if god
made it fine he's in here with us he's
trapped in this prison together with us
like i say space is the largest prison
never built
you can't bring you can't build you
can't create you can't design
nothing
i mean i do that every day
i do nothing every day no you can you
can you can model you can morph you can
convert something into something else
but you can't convert nothing into
something
and you can't convert something into
nothing like they do in quantum
mechanics and general relativity and so
um
yeah we have differences opinion there
differences of theories
okay here we have
final point here on this one
and this is how uh
quantum mechanics again creates
particles they have this energy negative
and positive energy i guess female and
male
and somehow these morph into virtual
particles this is their
theory
they say this is happening every day
that particles pop in from the void and
then the same particles combine because
one is negative and the other one is
positive and they turn back into empty
space into vacuum this is the theory
that's out there so yeah they they have
creation of matter from the void
and they have
matter turning into void as well uh
that's mathematical physics for you
why because they're not interested in
physical interpretations this is all
magic this is not even magic it's
surrealistic it has no bearing
whatsoever in science
okay so for them to say that two
particles turned into space they turned
into nothing what do you mean are they
still there as particles
and they say no they annihilated what do
you mean by that what did they turn into
i mean they annihilated what happened
with the matter did 3d turn into no d
so this is these are the questions that
they don't answer they just said it
annihilated whatever that means and then
they say you should study math to find
out what that means means that turns
into a zero
and then the zero turns into a ten
that's all math that's got nothing to do
with physics
those are descriptions
okay um so let's get into the subject
matter today and again uh what i want to
focus on is not the math okay
there's a little bit of math here but
i'm just going to
use it to show you what the
mathematicians are thinking or how they
came to these ideas not because we're
interested in the math itself
the point here is to talk about physical
interpretations about mechanisms of how
the universe works okay that's the
bottom line
and the issue here is space time
you know does space time have anything
whatsoever to do with how the universe
works
we don't care about the math we don't
care about whether einstein broke his
head you know
doing his variables and numbers none of
that is of any significance in physics
in physics einstein has to explain why
the earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system that's what he's got to do in
physics
and if he cannot explain why
the earth or the moon or any planet for
that matter or any moon any satellite
does not leave the solar system
physically what prevents it from
physically leaving the solar system
he cannot explain that he has no
theory a description mathematical
description which is what these people
do is not a theory but that's what the
mathematicians call a theory
so they say oh the relativity theory
we're going to find out this so-called
relativity theory is not a theory it's
just a description because the theory is
bunk it's nonsense it's poppy cut and so
in other words the explanation they give
you for why
or how gravity works that's nonsense
it's total nonsense that's what we're
going to go over so again uh the math is
incidental okay don't pay attention to
the math here we go uh we start with
this fellow his name is abbott and
abbott
is important in this whole thing because
he wrote a book in 1884
and that book has to do with dimensions
dimensions as
americans call it a british color
dimension i always use dimension anyways
um he called it flatland and there he
talks specifically
uh about uh dimensions and what's
important about this is that even to
this day
this book that's why i say it's the most
important book of general relativity
this book is the one that's used to
explain to you why we cannot visualize
why we cannot imagine space-time why
because space-time is four-dimensional
why can't you imagine it well because we
are unfortunately three-dimensional
beings we were stuck in three dimensions
and say what's that got to do with
anything well imagine if you were a
flatlander
two-dimensional flatmander you could not
be able to imagine a three-dimensional
world because you only
can see your flat land you know your two
dimensions you're a square a triangle or
circle you can't see cubes and spheres
and
pyramids
and likewise we cannot imagine the four
dimensional world because we're stuck in
this three-dimensional world
that's the
analogy that's the argument and it all
comes from this book
that's part of it the other part of why
this is important why it's the most
important book in relativity is that
you know special relativity it's called
special
because it's a special case of general
relativity
what's so special about it
it's gravity less
there's no gravity
involved in uh
a special relativity
and
that's the world of flat land because
flatman has no gravity
you can't fall
in gravity because there is no down
okay
so all you have all you have is sideways
motion and so in a way
abbott killed two birds with one stone
on the one hand he he
uh
essentially described why you know many
things about the dimensions of assuming
that you live in flatland you would not
be able to understand the third
three-dimensional world and the other
one is that it's a perfect analogy for
special relativity which is again a
world of two dimensions you can say
there's there's no gravity okay there's
no down
okay
okay so this is where we start
and um
where this takes us is that in the uh
this was 1884 1887 you had uh these two
fellows michaelson and marty they ran an
experiment
actually a series of experiments in
which they proved that there was no
ether
of course many dissidents to this day
say oh there is an ether you just
misinterpreted the results blah blah
blah blah blah okay
so there's a lot of dissidents uh
believe in the ether the establishment
does not okay so assuming there's i
don't know 10 of the people out there
are
people who are interested in the subject
and they are dissidents well only 10
percent of them if anything believe
in the ether 90 percent of those who
bow down to the establishment who uh
tell the party line they do not believe
in the ether
or so they claim as you saw mr uh
laughlin he said they do believe in the
ether they just don't want to call it
that because it's
okay
okay so a fellow that came right after
that
around those days uh late 19th century
was laurence and lawrence
essentially made popular what's called
the lawrence factor
and you see it there uh it's that little
equation there gamma equation there
gamma equal to one over square root of
one
minus velocity squared over c squared c
squared being the velocity of light
squared what that little equation does
is say that as that little v
squared right as that little v velocity
your velocity
it approaches the speed of light 300 000
kilometers per second
as it approaches that
uh
one minus that uh ratio
gives you a very small number
and that very small number when you have
one divided by a very small number it
gives you a very big number meaning
gamma is a very big number
and they use that gamma they multiply it
times time
and they say oh lots of time
they multiply it times weight
mass right they see lots of mass
and they divide length
below b
by a gamma and they said oh length
contracted to very small
and this is where the ideas of traveling
at near the speed of light come where
you have length contraction mass
increase and time dilation
now this
again this already was in the 1890s
in fact it came before that in 18 uh
what was it 1887 you had this fellow
voight who already put that little
the the
key part which is that square root one
minus uh v over c right
he already came up with that
1887.
why is that important well because
einstein fell named albert einstein he
was only eight years old at the time
einstein was born in 1879.
so he was only eight years old when this
fell void uh german right
uh he already had this uh this square
root uh one minus v over c
and so
this length contraction was already
debated way before einstein published
anything on special relativity and
general relativity we're talking about
20 years before that
and so what do i mean by that you know
all these people they worked on there's
a lot of mathematicians were working on
the speed of light and what happens if
you travel at the speed of light they
came up with all these equations
and einstein's the guy who took the
credit and to this day takes the credit
for all of it everybody assigns all this
credit to einstein as if he was the only
mathematician alive in those days
and they forget about all these i mean
you talked to anyone on the street and
said you know who albert einstein was
and they said of course i know he said
you know who lawrence was do you know
who
heavyside was
they wouldn't know who i'm talking about
and so
all these people came up with all these
things einstein took the credit that's
my only point but the other well that's
the first point the second point is what
you see there uh when lawrence came up
with all this notion they started
looking at whether the ether existed
they were trying to incorporate the
ether within what they observed they
came up with these equations they try to
justify the ether one way or another
because
you know these people believe strongly
in the ether they grew up with the ether
just like people today grew up with
space time with black holes and big bang
go talk to them and say there's no such
thing as dark matter dark energy or
black holes or big bang they'll kill you
and these people were no different they
were born with the ether and you
couldn't tell them that the ether did
not exist they said what do you mean the
ether doesn't exist of course it does
exist but michael said to marty prove
that it doesn't exist well
let's accommodate that let's let's find
out if that's true and so they
they try to work around that to try to
justify the ether at all costs because
they believe strongly this generation
believes strongly in the
ether what they did was they entered the
rabbit hole because they started working
with time they started playing around
with time or with this gamma factor okay
this lawrence factor
and so yeah it started getting very
weird because they started playing with
time and they said well if we travel at
near the speed of light
what happens to length what happens to
mass what happens to
um
time itself
and of course
what happened here was
they forgot about reality
and they were just concentrating on math
why because measurement only has to do
with math in physics we're not
interested in measurement at all we want
to have an explanation of how the
universe works we want to know how
gravity works and these people say let
me measure it
so what if you measure it i mean you
know here
my famous trick we let go of the pencil
and falls to the ground so you measure
something you measure the weight
uh the mass if you want whatever you
measure the speed you measure how much
time so what
can you tell me why the pen falls to the
floor not to the ceiling
you can't tell me by saying mass you
can't tell me by saying
uh
you know gravity you can't tell me by
saying uh you know speed or time
you will not tell me with any of those
notions
what causes the pen to fall to the floor
instead of to the ceiling okay so this
is the problem we had mathematicians
dealing with a problem and they thought
they were trying to figure out how
gravity works by doing math
and that's where we stand today to this
day nobody can tell you why that pencil
falls to the ground not one person on
earth except uh us you know here we have
a we do have a
an explanation a physical interpretation
but we're the only group
and uh so what did lawrence come up with
well he already had the notion of what
is known as time dilation okay this is
essentially what uh he came up with okay
that the uh you have a train
going by and you have passenger on the
train and a passenger and um you know
someone on an observer on the platform
and in the case above we were talking
about the passenger on the on the train
and you know if lightning hits the front
of the train and the back of the train
at the same time
the passenger
will see the front of the train hit her
first before the one in the back because
he's traveling in that direction and
light has a shorter time to travel to
his eyes
okay so that's that's the notion uh from
the passengers point of view how about
the observer on the platform well for
him it happens simultaneously because he
sees
he's equidistant from both
you know points the front and the back
of the drain that's essentially it
what this did was introduce the observer
into physic into well mathematics as we
call it okay because now people were
concerned about what you perceive
why because they were talking about
measurement
so well you're measuring something and
i'm measuring something different well
that's because you're moving at the
speed of light
and so if you move
in this direction i move in the other
direction we're going to have different
measurements and we have to account for
that in our measurements
it all had to do with measurement
measurement measurement nothing to do
with physics
has to do with descriptions with
calculating stuff
we still don't know what causes gravity
but these people are talking about you
know time dilation
mass increase length contraction all
this nonsense that they came up with
and just to rub it in here we have pon
coire and uh andrei pancore and
he essentially enunciated the principle
of relativity
also given to einstein and henri was
quite angry about that he said look we
worked all these mathematicians we
worked for several
couple decades at least 20 years
and this new
newbie he comes in there he takes all
the credit for it
he he's a creative special relativity
he's the creator of time dilation all
this stuff when we've talked for 20
years for this about this
and so yeah he wrote a paper there uh
actually he gave a speech but
he wrote the paper in 1904 remember the
uh
annis mirabili that
einstein had in 1905 one year later okay
and here we're talking about poincare he
came to the united states he gave this
speech in saint louis
and it's called what the principles of
mathematical physics
and what i liked is in there one of the
headings is the present crisis of
mathematical physics
sounds like the year
2022
we're still with a crisis in
mathematical physics nothing has changed
in you know over a hundred years
and so yeah he enunciated the uh
poincare
enunciated the principle of relativity
that's not einstein's
and uh he says the poem he says
concerning the ether he says the ether
is how its molecules are disposed etc
etc and then in that same paper he says
the atoms of ether
what is the ether what did the
etherist believe in
they believed it was a bunch of
particles
atoms molecules particles points
whatever you want to call them
okay so the ether uh was a bunch of
parties a body a fluid a field whatever
you want to call it i don't care it
doesn't matter doesn't change anything
because fields uh waves um
vortices
energy all these words mean the same
thing
they they are a standalone
uh they are they are standing for lots
of particles
that's what they're talking about it's
always been simulated with particles and
it can't be any other way because
mathematics
can only put a value in an equation and
that value has to be represented with a
single point
for example a field
what is a field bunch of points and when
you talk about what's the strength of
the field here they're talking about the
strength of field at that point at that
location and they designate it with a
point with a dot
that's why it's always been
dots and points and particles nothing's
changed the only thing that's changed
when quantum
and relativity also came later on they
turned those so-called particles into
abstractions
they got rid of the particle altogether
they said well the vibra what is a
particle it's a vibration of a field
it's the excitation of a field you're
seeing the hump
of a field
and that's a particle so what is a
particle a field and what is a field a
particle
no different they're synonyms okay
just values that mathematics has
invented to try to give some physicality
to their equations that's how it is
okay so here we have another foul who
came around the same time and his name
was minkowski
and what did he come up with well he
came up with a notion of space time in
fact there's a debate some other people
lived in those days that also talked
about space time among them juan coren
okay but he says in this paper he
published 1908 space and time he says
the views of space and time which i wish
to lay before you have sprung from the
soil of experimental physics again all
these people thought that with
experiments they they were doing science
okay no science is not about doing
experiments science is about explaining
rationally you have to explain give me a
rational explanation for a phenomenon
that's physics but these people said i'm
going to do an experiment
so what here i'll do an experiment for
you i'll let go of the pen
there it goes i let go of the pen fell
to the ground how many times more times
should i do it
that's gravity and now you got to
explain it
to say that you're gonna do an
experiment what more experiments do you
wanna do for gravity you gotta explain
it at some point not do experiments but
these people believed in experiments and
to this day people believe in
experiments
they think uh science is about doing
experiments so do an experiment let go
of the pen in your house
everybody today go ahead and let go of a
pen in your house and you'll find out it
falls to the floor
unless there's you know some magnet out
there that's holding it up
it'll fall to the floor
how many more experiments do you want to
do
what what's the purpose of doing more
experiments now you gotta explain it
why does it fall to the floor what comes
in contact with the pen is the question
because if you don't put something in
contact with a pen you are doing black
magic you're saying that spirits are
bringing it down
you can't say well mass and the energy
in the field no because there's a
concept we need a physical object you
can say that a tree pulled it down you
can say a rope pulled it down you can
say uh i don't know a wire pulled it
down that you can say you can say a dog
pulled it down you cannot say a field
put it pulled it down or energy pulled
it down or you know or mass or gravity
or whatever
okay you can talk about particles if
you're talking about real particles you
know then you can say that particles
pushed it down okay that's acceptable
as long as you talk about particles okay
you would have other problems but that's
beside the point the point is you can
use particles to to push the pen down
you can use that you cannot say a field
brought it down or energy brought it
down those words are concepts you can't
use those words and saying that's like
saying love pulled it down
because love is attractive i guess
anyways uh he says henceforth space by
itself and time by itself are doomed to
fade away into mere shadows and only a
kind of union of the two space time
will preserve an independent reality and
so uh
that's more or less 1908 that's when
this notion of space-time target started
taking shape
okay in the minds of all these
mathematicians
and
what were they talking about they were
talking about length width and height
and time and they converted time
into a dimension which is what abbott
had said more or less and uh he talked
about diamonds he didn't talk about time
but you know these were the days where
time became a dimension because people
were
trying to measure time they they were
saying well what happens if you travel
at the speed of light well then what
happens to time well it's stretched
it dilates you know and so that's when
they get into trouble because they
didn't the semantics
was up not up to par
and to this day it's not up to par so
they talk about time dilation you say
what do you mean time dilation are we
stretching time well you're not supposed
to take it so literally
so what did you mean
okay i mean we're gonna talk physics
let's talk physics
okay and then this fall came around in
1915 he wrote his paper uh albert
einstein
and he said gravity is warp time
and he says it's time that is bent it's
warped and that's what prevents the moon
from leaving
the earth
or the earth from leaving the solar
system or jupiter from leaving your
solar system
warp time
and say bill you're making fun of these
people you're not being serious now
no i'm i'm being deadly serious this is
the explanation you get
for why the earth doesn't leave the
solar system
that there's a depression
and the earth is rolling around the
edges of this depression like a ball
around a roulette that's the physical
interpretation that's the mechanism
they illustrate for you okay you don't
believe me here it is again i didn't
create this okay here it is okay
that's the moon and it goes around a
depression
what is that depression into what is
that blue stuff with all these
white lines going through it
well that canvas is known as space-time
this is a uh
you could say a three-dimensional
version of space-time they say they
cannot produce a four-dimensional one
fine we'll we'll concede for the sake of
argument
but what we're interested here is in the
mechanism they're saying the moon
doesn't leave the solar system or
doesn't leave the orbit of the earth
because it rolls around
warped
time that uh
blue canvas with white lines that space
time
you're bending time if they even say
they tell you that gravity warps time
they say these words so i'm not
inventing anything i'm not putting words
in their mouth okay this is the
mechanism that they explain
what do they respond when you say that
to them
well they say bill you're not supposed
to take the analogy so literally
well if i don't take it so literally
what have you explained what is the
mechanism
why doesn't the earth leave the solar
system why doesn't the moon leave the
solar system if that was just an analogy
whatever you meant by that
i mean i need to know what comes up
against the skin of the earth and you're
telling me it's warped time
that portion of space time
warp time is coming up against the skin
of the planet that's that's what you
illustrated
and then when i say you mean you have
warped time
and you say we're not supposed to take
it so literally
then what am i supposed to i mean i'm
asking for an explanation why the earth
doesn't leave the solar system i have to
take it literally whatever you give me
and so here it is this is the answer
they give you okay okay
says understanding gravity space time is
like a rubber sheet massive objects
distort the sheet and wait
student says they distort it because
they're pulled down by what
and the teacher said huh
my god
space-time is like this set of equations
for which any analogy must be what an
approximation
what does an equation have to do with
this
and so the the people who created this
say oh that's so boring no no it's not
boring it's irrational
the guy is irrational he's trying to get
away by saying look you got to study
math to understand what we're saying if
i studied all the math in the world all
i would have is a description i want an
explanation of why the earth doesn't
leave the solar system
and if the guy says it's because it's uh
bending
the earth is bending the rubber sheet
and that's why the moon doesn't fly away
and the sun is bending the rubber sheet
and that's why the earth doesn't fly
away then that's analogy is what his ex
that's what his explanation is
he can't later on deny it and say well
you're hanging on every word that i say
of course i do it's got to be literal
physics is literal
okay you can't
bs your way with equations and numbers
and variables
that's where the problem is these people
are giving you a description and selling
it to you you know
like a used car salesman or a guy who
sells you some snake oil and it's trying
to pass it as an explanation and when
you focus on the explanations
it's just a description of mathematical
description you got to take math to
understand what we're saying you have to
look at equations
those are descriptions
i want an explanation
so they don't have
an explanation for gravity
because when you call their bluff they
say
you're not supposed to take it so
literally
that's the that's the answer you get
okay so be aware that's what it is
and uh that it is a description is uh
certified here by mr stephen hawking
okay and here he says an event is
something that happens at a particular
point in space
in a particular
time
it is often helpful to think of the four
coordinates of an event as specifying
its position in a four-dimensional space
called space-time it is impossible to
imagine a four-dimensional space
that's out of his book a brief history
of time bestseller okay
and so he's saying look this is all the
concept this is not an explanation
okay he just thinks that it's a helpful
to think of it
as a four-dimensional as a
four-coordinate event
what is that that's a description he
hasn't told me why the earth doesn't fly
out of the solar system or why he
doesn't fly out of his wheelchair there
okay so
this is where we stand they have
descriptions they're selling it to you
as an explanation there is no
explanation for gravity or like mr thoth
victor toss said a couple weeks ago you
know when we analyze him
what did he say he says we're still
investigating
yeah they're going to be investigating
another 400 years because they have no
clue whatsoever what causes gravity and
that's what people want to know the
layman wants to know why that pen falls
to the floor why this baby spoon fell to
the floor they don't want you to give
them some equation
that describes how fast it fell what the
weight was
people want to know the mechanism
and that's where mathematical physics
fails and space-time is not going to
help you space-time is a four-coordinate
description
of gravity that's all it is okay
and uh just in case uh to top it off we
have mr ain't
just want to make sure that we
understand that he still believe that
space-time
it has to do with the ether okay
says we may say that according to the
general theory of relativity space is
endowed with physical qualities in this
sense therefore there exists an ether
according to the general theory of
relativity space without ether is
unthinkable
he said that in 1920 one year after his
theory was so-called certified by arthur
eddington when he did his um
picture of an eclipse and he found that
a star
behind the sun he could see it why
because he says the light curved around
the sun
that's what
this poor guy arthur eddington concluded
that
uh light was bent as they say today or
warped
it never occurred to him that uh what
he's talking about not bent but
deflected because if he's going to talk
about photons he's got to use the right
language he can't say light is bent he's
got to say light is deflected because
he's talking about particles what is
mathematical physics about particles
it's always been about particles they
never left the particles
okay so yeah that's the first problem
the second problem is we have a
different explanation for that we don't
need the little
photons to curve
around the sun to be deflected by the
warping of space-time which is a concept
again they use space-time as a physical
object when you put it to them and say
are you saying time is warped
because that's what they're telling you
and they say well you're not supposed to
take it literally
then what have we learned
we're running around in circles we're
warp space i guess you know
depression
okay
so what are my conclusions for this
space-time thingy here's a rundown
space-time resulted from the necessity
of discarding the 2000 year old ether
towards the end of the 19th century the
ether was dying
and a few people tried to save it at the
beginning of the 20th century but they
had no luck eventually the ether went
away
really the word went away but the
concept stayed because even to this day
like mr laughlin says
what they deal with is the ether they
just don't call it that because it is
taboo
but space-time is an ether theory what
is ether a bunch of particles what is
space-time
uh well i think habitat distance have
never offered an alternative to
particles that's the first thing you
need to know in math physics uh
and among old dissidents right space is
made of particles some say space is
infinite others say it's finite and
whenever you use two adjectives like
those you're talking about a physical
object
adjectives can only be applied to
objects but
[Music]
one of the main points is that space
time introduced into math physics the
fall the false continuing the fake
continuity
why because they talk about the space
time continuum see with discrete
particles you don't have any continuous
of anything everything is discrete
everything is segmented
and somehow you have to tie it all
together if you're going to talk about
action at a distance
and that's one of the things that
general relativity introduced for the
first time in mathematics
they introduced continuity they can the
space space-time continuum you know
there's space-time is this rubber sheet
that extends all the way from the sun to
the earth from the earth all the way to
the moon so it's a continuous
um
entity
medium and so now you can talk about
action at a distance because you say
whatever the earth does here it affects
the moon over there because the
vibrations move through the space
through these through space-time through
the rubber sheet right they treat it as
a rubber sheet space time
it's warped warp time and when you
confront them they say well it's just an
analogy you're not supposed to take it
literally okay
but gr uh general relativity space-time
is made of points known as events
that's why it's an ether theory
each point
i mean what is ether a bunch of
particles
uh what is space-time a bunch of points
what is a point an event in space time
that's what it is so
space-time is an ether theory an ether
proposal it's made out of points
but somehow it's continuous
you see so they covered both
all the bases they said it's discrete
but it's also continuous okay meaning
it's all connected
okay so
they needed to cover both worlds so that
they could explain gravity to you
okay they say where does the earth
affect the moon well because it's a
continuous rubber sheet
rubber sheet of what of time
time is a physical object you're not
supposed to take it literally
stay space time is an irrational
mathematical theory meaning it's not a
theory at all it's a description that
states that the earth doesn't fly out of
the solar system because time is worked
that's what space time is all about they
call it a geometric theory of gravity
it's got nothing to do with geometry
because geometry first and foremost is
about
figures
the zero dimensional point the
one-dimensional line are not figures at
all
but those are the foundations of
geometry we covered that in a couple
last couple sessions
so
mathematical physics
especially general relativity is founded
on this notion of geometry which is in
itself founded on irrational proposals
which is the zero dimensional point
meaning location and the one-dimensional
line meaning itinerary
okay and so that's what
geometry is
and space time or general relativity is
supposed to be a geometric theory of
gravity what is it space time and what
is space time time which is warped and
that's what they say gravity is
i hope you got all that it's going to be
on the test on friday
okay let's move on to the questions and
comments people made since last time we
had several of these i'm not going to
cover them all uh
the questions people made comments uh
if i miss your question your comment
please put it up again okay one follows
us no one knows how or why anything is
what it is
and that brings to mind uh the famous
latin saying says um
ignoramus
ignorabimus
we do not know and will not know
so that's been around for quite a while
okay
and yeah ignorant people say that
because the first thing you should know
is that in science we do not use the
word no
knowledge belongs exclusively to
religion when you know something
it means you believe it
you're certain of it and that's you
okay it doesn't mean i believe in it or
that i certify it or that i approve it
okay if i'm your boss for sure i'm not
gonna prove
okay so when you know something it's
because you believe it
you are certain of it you meaning he
said well so are the mathematicians well
yeah
so now you have two people who believe
in it three people four people is it the
question of how many people believe in
it
i mean
is god for
true
does god exist
god created the universe
well you believe in as you may say you
know that god exists well the other guy
the atheist says god doesn't exist
so knowledge is not a part of science
you can't use the word now no in science
every time you use the word no you're
talking about religion okay so please
don't know anything okay in science we
explain
we do not know we explain so that you
understand not that you believe in other
words no in other words believe
okay okay fellow says i can't imagine uh
[Music]
uh no i said for uh the other day i said
you can't imagine 1d object okay the 1d
accent he says your argument also
applies to 2d two dimensions
okay no one can imagine a
two-dimensional object that has no depth
that's illogical
three dimension is the minimum for
physical existence
well there's a two-dimensional object
if i can illustrate it for you certainly
i can imagine it
i mean
what problems you have are you blind or
or what's your problem
i mean there you have it it's a
two-dimensional object obviously i can
imagine it because i drew it
i mean the one-dimensional one can you
can you illustrate the one-dimensional
one like i illustrated the
two-dimensional triangle
and the answer is no you can't
illustrate a one-dimensional anything or
a zero-dimensional anything okay so yeah
i illustrated it but let's go with the
fallacy this poor fellow suffers
from
all kinds of fallacies okay here it is
first the definition of object okay an
object is that which has shape
and
two-dimensional whatever has shape
one-dimensional or zero-dimensional
whatever don't have shape there is no
shape there to begin with because you
cannot produce the shape
out here
you might say well i i can see it here
well if you can see it you should be
able to put it out here i mean i can
imagine a two-dimensional triangle and i
put it out there and prove to you that i
can imagine it prove to me that you can
imagine a one-dimensional whatever okay
and
he creates objects with existence see
what he did here he says three dimension
is the minimum for physical existence
we're not talking about existence why
did you bring the word exist into this
discussion
see again all these people confused just
like um
david hume and emmanuel kent
they believed that there's no difference
between an object and exist
object and a thing and existence they
said it's a synonym
that they didn't know what the the word
existence added to the word object
and what it adds to it is location they
never figured it out
an object with location exists an object
without location does not exist
so if you have a
vision in your head of a
three-dimensional table you might see it
in two dimensions
that table does not exist because it has
no location
there is nothing there's no table inside
your head what it is you have electrical
chemical
processes going on in there that create
this thought this vision
okay but out here
table exists if you see it there why
because it has location that's the
definition of the word location
uh the word exists okay
so this again he confuses existence with
location that's one issue then um
do the head shape
anything that's two dimensional
squares
circle they have shape so that's what an
object is an object is that which has
shape do not confuse that with the
notion of ordinary speech
the notion of object of ordinary speech
which is that which you can see or touch
that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about the def the
scientific definition of the word object
that which has shape not that which you
can see or touch you can't see or touch
the table that the klingon has on the
other side of the universe but that
table is an object hopefully the word
table is always an object referring to
the furniture right
okay and again the 1d doesn't have shape
and objects that exist are 3d and have
location that's what existence means
exist means an object that has location
and for that you have to have three
dimensions there is no such thing as a
two-dimensional
uh
object that has location
or uh
or an object whatsoever that is one
dimension or a zero dimensional or
four-dimensional or greater
okay a lot of questions on god
uh phil says rational science none of
that these days big bang is equal god
said there be light and bang light
became
okay and to think it took a lifetime for
the most renowned
atheist to come to the conclusion that
where there is
a grand designed there must be a
designer
aha so he says that because you have a
grand design in this case the universe
right the stars the galaxies all that
stuff uh there had to be a designer for
all that
okay you have a grand design you have a
grand designer
okay so let's follow his train of
thought let's see where it leads okay
here we have it okay
uh god is also a grand design because
god is almighty and he allegedly created
the universe right he's all-knowing
right etc so pursuant to this falls
logic there must be a designer that
designed god
and so the question is what's on the
other side of that uh
uh
magic wand
is that a god's father is it god's
mother is it a magician an angel
okay who created god who designed god
he's also grand design
so all these people they feel logic at
the basic stuff
you know i mean if the guy's going to
say that grand design requires a
designer well then
god requires a designer he can't say
well for that i'm not going to use a
designer god has always been around
which is one of the arguments out there
very simple we don't need god at all we
can say matter has always been around
which is what we say
matter has always been around and that's
easy to prove because matter cannot
convert into space and space cannot
convert into matter
something cannot convert into nothing
and nothing cannot convert it to
something very simple we're done we
don't need god at all
okay get rid of god
okay uh another foul says what's oh no
this is in in line with that as well the
watchmaker analogy they say you know the
designer the creator okay and so they
use this watchmaker that a watch had to
have a watch maker
you find a watch on the sea you know on
a beach
and you see it with all these intricate
uh you know things in there you say well
this could have been made by
nature
this had to have a maker a designer a
creator
an intelligence or a human who
toiled and worked on it okay
and you know i've got that in my book
and why god doesn't exist okay and these
are just in general terms uh it goes
into a little more detail but these are
the main points is they watch a living
entity because say they say god created
humans
well can you say that creating a watch
is the same thing as creating a human
are those
similar processes
that's the first issue you should
consider
is it sounded comparable being like man
to a watch
did a rock have a rock maker
you know you find a rock on a mountain
whoa
a rock
i mean
you find a watch you say well that had a
watchmaker well did a rock have a rock
maker
okay or is it just too blunt to be able
to say that that required god to make it
could have been made by the earth okay
so again if you're going to say watch
and tree and dog and everything else
well
uh is a crystal made by god or was that
made in some other way
okay
did the rock maker climb the mountain
and placed the rock up there okay then
you take all that trouble okay and then
you have erie and uri and um miller
what was it i think 1951 1952
they attempted to create life
and they failed they were able to create
amino acids
they took some
i think methane
and they had it in
some kind of flask they gave it a shot
of electricity
and a few days later they had some amino
acids form in there
now amino acids is not life okay so
that's straightforward okay but it's one
of the components of dna you know so
you can say that um
you know
it's one of the components of life
and they were able to create that
like creating one of the missing links
in the whole chain of life
and in that sense you could say it's an
important experiment but they were not
able to create life
what do i mean by that well then we
continue here so far humans can't create
life
therefore we have evidence that
intelligence can't create life
not the opposite we can't say
intelligence created life because so far
intelligence has not been able to create
life that's the proof that's the
evidence of what we have out there
humans have the highest intelligence
available in the universe
and a lot of people roll their eyes say
oh my god what is he saying
yes
we have the highest in talent mother
nature has ran out of uh blessings to
give us
we are the highest intelligence possible
in the universe and of course when we
reach this level of intelligence uh it's
the end of man
so it confirms once again that we are
the last humans on earth
uh you know we don't uh have super
intelligence there's no such thing as no
such monster as super intelligence so we
have more and more and more and more
intelligence
what intelligent do you want i mean if
if you're shortchanged you gotta
complain to your mother sue her i don't
know she made you like that but
you know it's there's no sin of
superintelligence
you should be able to understand
anything that any human wants to explain
to you god almighty or the devil himself
comes here right now he should be able
to explain gravity to you what causes
gravity and you should be able to
understand it
what more intelligence do you want than
that
i mean what kind of intelligence are you
expecting
and people say oh all the super
intelligence that the klingons have out
there
you know uh there's no such thing
humans have the highest intelligence
that can evolve in any planet in the
universe when they reach a high level of
intelligence that's about it because
humanity dies at that point it dies
wherever it's in the universe it doesn't
matter
finally it dies because uh the
population pyramid overturns and because
of that the economy collapses the last
dynasty of humanoids or
what is it hominins hominids etc
okay therefore there is no evidence that
intelligence
uh designed or created life we have no
evidence today that
life can be created by intelligence okay
so
for those of you who
are religious who've been taught in
sunday school that intel
there had to be a designer who created
life very simple we have no evidence
that intelligence can create or can
design life
very simple we can probably understand
it created is a different thing and by
creating it i mean in the lab of course
we can create life through
uh a female you know that's not creating
life that's just uh
reproducing you know like any animal out
there or or even plant for that matter
they you know plants put the seed down
of new tree grows now we're talking
about creating it in the lab you know
artificially okay by but with your hands
not not through your body
okay another issue related to god here
it says you say that there is a problem
with accepting that god was always there
since this movie starts with frame
number two yeah
because uh if god is already there we
don't know how god came into existence
right
so we don't know what happened frame
number one when you put in say god
created the universe all you're doing is
starting at frame number two i want to
know what happened in frame number one
that's got to do with big bang because
big bang also starts at frame number two
we have no idea what happened to frame
number one how did this singularity
this
densely packed whatever
uh where did that come from
that's what so we want to know what
happened frame number one not in frame
number two
and you know mathematical physics
conveniently stops at frame number two
okay and so if i says
what's the problem if your request is to
find what happened to the beginning we
don't need to know who was there but
what he did
this is this is how
religious people are so irrational
they don't even ask these questions it
doesn't bother them at all they don't
want to know who how god came into being
he said that's not important we want to
know what god did on that day
poor fellow
again he's got to complain to his mother
some people like that yeah they say yeah
we'll never know anything because they
don't understand anything you know you
didn't tell us what the beginning
exactly you're talking about
yes i i have told you that but you
missed it
i'm talking about how matter
came into being in other words how did
space nothing vacuum
turn into something
objects matter that's what we're talking
about
that's what i talk about when i say the
beginning i want to know how the first
atom came into being
okay do we have that that's the
beginning
and so
here's the answer formal answer
uh who told you first that there was a
who where did he get this who deal okay
he invented that
that's an irrational proposal to say
that there was a who
and again you know uh
intelligence
cannot design life we have no evidence
of that we are the highest intelligence
in the universe we cannot create life
space in other words nothing can't turn
into matter something and matter
something can't morph into space nothing
okay
matter was always there no one created
matter
only in the religion of mathematical
physics and in traditional religions do
they propose creationism
in other words big bang in other words
that matter came into existence that's
what we're talking about here okay
okay let's get rid of this
give me a second here
okay another fellow says
to exist means as shown in the video
to have a physical presence
okay good good he said meaning me right
no one has defined what exists means in
the last ten thousand years
exactly
then he accepts it means physical
presence
i mean
some people are total dense
totally dense
what are you gonna say to this poor
fella he he doesn't have a brain
i guess he picked up the scarecrow's
brain you know when
when the scarecrow left oz
he doesn't realize i mean where did he
get the this definition of physical
presence
did he find it in a dictionary
i mean he likes it apparently he says
to exist means as shown in the video to
have physical presence good i like that
okay
then he accepts it means physical
presence yeah
but he says
no one has he find that i say that no
one has he find exists when i say it's
physical presence so how come i say that
no one has defined it if it's defined as
physical presence
so here are my answers this poor fellow
poor poor fellow he's just
not even close i mean these are the
answers where did you get that
definition
please look up the definition of exist
in any dictionary on planet earth past
present or future see if you can find
this definition physical present that
you love so much
tell me in which dictionary you found
that definition in other words exist is
equal to physical presence
okay
so that's homework for you if you can
answer that question hey i'll give you a
million dollars okay
that a fear i'll buy you a beer
if you can tell me where you got that
definition
where did you hear it where did you find
it what dictionary i want to find it
okay that's the that's the answer to you
when you figure that out you'll figure
out everything
what
mental problem these people have okay
here's a i think the same phone if i say
george x exists would you respond how do
you know
now only an idiot would ask how do you
know okay
that's not the question the question is
um
please define the word exist
that's what i would ask you to
to that's the question i would ask you
don't don't say if x exists how would
you know it has nothing to do with
knowledge knowledge but the word
knowledge the word no belongs to
religion exclusively it has no place in
science knowledge is exclusively
religion when you when you know
something means you got a religion
you believe it
that's all it means okay so we don't use
the word knowledge the word no in
science
in science you have to define the word
exists and then we'll know
whether george exists or not we just
follow the definition we apply the
definition to george x and we'll know
right
meaning we we can make the assumption
that
george exists because it follows the
definition of exist which is what
physical presence i wonder where he got
that definition what dictionary was that
from
is he an object or a concept
okay if george refers to an object then
george may be said to exist if george
has location
okay
if george refers to a concept
right if that's what george means right
then the definition of exist makes it
irrational to say that george exists
okay so uh i hope that's understood
only objects can exist in science you
cannot have a concept that exists in
science you cannot say that love exists
not in science you cannot say
intelligence exists you cannot say data
exists
you can't use concepts and say you
cannot say energy exists or a field
exists
no such monsters in physics in physics
only objects can be said to exist you
can say a tree exists you can say a dog
exists you can say a house exists why
because they have location
physical presence you cannot say that
a house that you're imagining exists
because it has no location house is an
object but if it's the one that you're
thinking of that one doesn't exist it
has no location no separation between
your house the one that you have in your
brain and my trust because your house
that has no
location
okay uh another file says
then he said uh saint paul says then he
says we don't define objects why not who
told them that
yeah we don't define objects we point to
them
you have the klingon he comes and visits
us right from klingon land
he wants to learn your language and you
say well tree
what do you mean tree what is tree
and the way you are going to teach them
your language that when you're going to
teach them the word tree is by pointing
and saying tree
you don't say well look a tree
is this object right that has leaves and
has branches and it's brown
grows in summer and
he has no idea what you're talking about
you have to point and say tree then he
knows what the word tree means
that's how we present objects in physics
in science okay
the description is irrelevant okay we
don't care about descriptions so no we
don't describe we point and name that's
how we do it in physics so uh we don't
define objects as soon as you start
defining you're talking about a concept
only
okay concepts we define objects we point
to
when we see a new device of some kind
what do we say we say what is that
then we wait to hear what it is a
description
he's got all kinds of mental problems i
don't know this poor phone is completely
out of it no absolutely not only
irrational folk wait for a description
okay
now you
first of all he's confusing ordinary
speech with science that's that's his
main problem there okay and yeah if
you're going to confuse you're going to
use this notion of ordinary speech which
is see and touch and you say oh that's a
computer what do you mean what is the
computer and well it's this thing over
here and blah blah blah you know
now the way it is you point a name
that's how we present objects in physics
that's the scientific version okay the c
touch let me see it let me touch it
describe it that's all ordinary speech
he doesn't understand that
okay
well it says when we say god we mean the
being personality that created
everything
being personality
uh split personality here we have being
on one side personality and the other
looks like we're talking about two
different things being is an object
personality is a concept okay let's see
we are then talking about a person okay
we are not talking about an object
so he's saying that god is not an object
but god is a being
okay
we are
talking about a person but he's saying
person is personality and personality is
not an object
uh-huh
well
first of all it's just
absolute utter nonsense what this poor
fellow has got in his brain or it
doesn't have much between his ears being
is always an object always a thing you
look up the word being it says a living
what thing
a living thing what is the thing that
which has shape
that's what it is in science not in
ordinary speech
an ordinary speech is that which you can
see or touch in science it's that which
has shape so either god has shape or god
don't have shape one of the two can't be
both
like in
dualities of mathematics no it either
has shape or it don't
okay just that simple black or white no
gray
okay so if
uh god is a being
then we're talking about a thing
and god has shape that's what we're
saying
if god don't have shape
then god is a concept
and in that case you can't even talk
about the existence of god because only
objects may be said to exist if they
have
presence location okay
and it is irrational to propose that
concepts such as personality created
matter
because if god is personality as god is
not an object
god is a concept
then concepts don't create objects
don't design concept don't design
objects i mean okay so you can't have
both ways if god is a concept if god is
not an object god is not a thing
meaning he's an abstract concept then
god could not have created the universe
because that one you really have to
explain how love created the universe or
how intelligence created the universe or
how data created the universe what does
that mean
please explain the mechanism of how this
concept created matter
okay
and so yeah this this is where these uh
religious people
fail completely they they have no
rationality whatsoever they never
are able to
explain to you a mechanism
and that's why what is other foul says
we know nothing will never know anything
yeah
religious people in science we don't
know science we explain so that you
understand the mechanism okay that's how
we do it in science okay uh here's
another
he says science is particular type of
study the purpose of that method is to
arrive to results pertaining to the
advance of knowledge in that field
again the word knowledge these people
think science is about knowledge because
they found the word science and comes
from syria which meant knowledge no the
latins the
greeks all these people failed
completely science has nothing to do
with with knowledge okay it's not
accumulation of knowledge and it has
nothing to do with studying
what if you study all week and you learn
nothing you got a zero on the test on
friday
so
just because you study you're a
scientist anyone who studies
is a scientist
so studying is the wrong word to define
the word science
you can't use the word study to define
science you can't say science is the
study of that's irrational
okay because anyone can study it does
that mean i mean even a baby can study
so the baby is a
is a
scientist because he studied
and knowledge is equal to religion okay
anyone using the word knowledge is
talking about religion you're talking
about what you know what you believe
belief is opinion and it's got to do
totally with religion in science we do
not have opinions we do not have beliefs
we do not know in science we explain so
that you understand not so that you
believe
and science attempts to explain things
science he said that right science
attempts to explain things and
science does but not mathematics and
he's referring to mathematics
mathematics does not explain in fact it
has no explanation whatsoever
and they don't claim to do explanations
and here's proof here's evidence here's
for your knowledge okay
this is uh richard feynman the more you
see how strangely nature behaves the
harder it is to make a model that
explains how even the simplest phenomena
actually work so theoretical physics has
given up on that in other words they
don't explain
and what does uh this professor say
donald simenek he says science doesn't
explain
science describes
and you have to replace the word science
with mathematics mathematical physics
they do not explain we have no
explanations for anything emanating from
mathematical physics to this day we have
no idea according to mathematics right
uh how gravity works we have no idea
from them how
magnetism works what light is how
electricity works well
how an atom works we have no
explanations whatsoever from
mathematical physics
so no they do not explain
we explain in this site here we explain
but every outside the site no one
explains anything
everybody just does descriptions with
particles
particles is what everybody uses and you
cannot explain a single phenomenon of
nature with particles that's where the
problem is you've got to get rid of the
particle hypothesis
okay here's another fellow he says
we can define all words to a certain
degree just like all things can be
described to a certain degree
the way he puts it meaning me right we
can claim that all words do not have a
definition
well the issue is that in science we do
not define every word in the dictionary
we do not have to we define only those
words that make or break our theories
we're going to give a presentation a
dissertation we have to define the key
words in that dissertation
those are the words we have to define
and in the case of physics the
foundations include the number one word
with which without which you can't do
physics and that's the word object you
need to define object
no one has ever defined the word object
in science in physics okay no one
okay
first person that not only defines it is
me
but
i defended i i i did something even more
important which is
understand the importance of defining
the word object you can't do physics
without objects you cannot give a
physical interpretation without the word
object you need absolutely to define the
word object and physics
and that's the first thing
because all these people are trying to
give a physical interpretation on the
one hand and we say but you're using a
concept well you're not supposed to take
the analogy literally over and over and
over again that's what they say
okay no if you're going to give a
physical interpretation you need to
define the word object you can't do
physical interpretations without object
and then you have to use the word exist
because you can only do it with if
you're going to explain the real
universe you have to explain uh
with objects that exist
and so you need to know what the word
exist means and yeah it's object that
has location physical presence
okay and so here's the answer to this
fella
and here it is we don't define all
objects all words in science the words
that are required are the ones that make
or break our theories we don't define
words to a certain degree either like a
gray area like saying well i defined it
uh to a dark gray no no it's got to be
black or white on and off yes or no
not one scientist has defined a single
word
needed to do physics specifically those
that lay the foundations of physics
specifically well i can name several of
them you know but the word object
the word exist
you need to define what location is you
need to define what distance is before
that because one of these is based on
the other one they're all it's a
comprehensive set
you know if you define objects then you
need to define distance which is the
separation
qualitative not distance traveled but
qualitative separation between two
objects you need to define location so
which is the set of distances from one
object to all the rest that's what it is
in the universe okay that's what it is
for physics and then it's very easy to
define motion as two or more locations
exist as object that has location and
concept
as a relationship between two objects
okay
what does the word concept mean it's a
word
that
invokes and involves
two objects all concepts involve two
objects two shapes
okay and final issue here false says
matter cannot be eternal
uh-huh if so then the universe would be
cyclical
okay so what if it's cyclical
i mean the father doesn't say any more
than that
if he would have elaborated a little bit
we would know what's inside his brain
but he says
it would be cyclical and so what i mean
is is that a crime or or what is it
against the law
i mean he doesn't explain this is shows
you the these people i mean why does he
put a comment if he's not going to
expand upon it
you would think that if he says it would
be cyclical and this is the problem with
it being cyclical you would think he
explains that but he doesn't do that he
just says it would be cyclical like we
got to read his brain and find out why
that's a problem so i say so what
so what if it's cyclical
okay and then whatever you meant by
cyclical because it could be
the alternating universe you know the
the fact that it has a beginning and
then goes back to beginning and then and
end and so on the oscillating universe
right could be anything who knows what
he's talking about um is he saying
history repeats itself uh uh is he
saying that objects will occupy the same
location in the next universe when it
begins all over again in the second
cycle
who knows what goes through this tiny
brain okay by what mechanism does
nothing morph into something
that's what he's got to explain
okay so
if he's going to say that matter cannot
be eternal he's saying it had a
beginning and if it had a beginning he's
got to explain the mechanism before he
says something dumb like he said there
he's got to say
this is the mechanism by which matter
came into existence okay
otherwise matter is eternal
okay so it's either eternal it's been
there forever
always has been always will be
or it was
space became matter at some point
nothing became something
and that's and when he's denying that
it's eternal he's saying that space
became
matter you know
vacuum turned into an atom that's what
he's saying okay show me tell me the
mechanism that's what we want to
understand what is the mechanism that
you propose how did space acquire length
width and height become something
okay which is the answer
no one can give you from mathematical
physics
and
again you can include god if you want in
there i mean
uh
let's assume god is already there
god already exists we'll concede okay
here's the magic wand
we can see god is already there
okay how does god
turn space nothing
into something
explain the mechanism
if you can't explain the mechanism
your theory is bunk
nonsense
and and i gave you god
what are you going to say he did it by
black magic he said abracadabra and
nothing turned into something is that
what you're going to tell me
is that the physics you're going to talk
about that you say matter is not eternal
with that i'll see you on
bye with